YEAR.
HE HAD A TRAVEL BAN IN PLACE
JANUARY 31.
I THINK THE DEMOCRATS WERE IN ET
MIDDLE OF IMPEACHMENT.
THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES, 45th PRESIDENT, DONALD
J TRUMP, THANK YOU FOR BEING
WITH US, SIR.
>> HELLO, SEAN.
>> I WANT TO TELL YOU GORSUCH,
KAVANAUGH, YOU HAVE RELEASED THE
WHIRL WIND, YOU WILL PAY THE
PRIZE, YOU WON’T KNOW WHAT HIT
YOU IF YOU GO FORWARD WITH THESE
AWFUL DECISIONS.
YOU HEARD FROM THE CHIEF JUSTICE
TODAY THAT SOUNDS LIKE THREAT TO
ME.
YOUR REACTION.
>> WELL, FIRST OF ALL LET ME
START BESEEING DR. SEGAL I
THOUGHT WAS TERRIFIC TONIGHT AND
I REALLY APPRECIATE THE WORDS, I
HAVE A LOT OF RESPECT FOR HIM,
HE IS A REAL PROFESSIONAL.
AS FAR AS SCHUMER IS CONCERNED,
IT WAS TERRIBLE THING HE SAID.
I WAS AMAZED BY IT AND IF THAT
WERE A REPUBLICAN YOU WOULD SEE
REALLY BAD THINGS HAPPENING IT
IS VERY UNEQUAL JUSTICE.
AND IT IS A DISGRACE THAT HE WAS
ABLE TO SAY SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
HE WASN’T SHIELDED BY THE HALLS
OF CONGRESS LIKE SCHIFF WAS WHEN
HE LIED ABOUT MY PHONE CALL
WHERE HE MADE UP A PHONE CALL
AND GAVE IT IN CONGRESS AND YOU
IMMEDIATELY SAY, GOOD, WE’LL
TAKE IT TO COURT BUT HE’S GOT
IMMUNITY BECAUSE HE IS TALKING
IN CONGRESS.
SO IT WAS A FAKE PHONE CALL, HE
JUST TOTALLY MADE IT UP, HIS
SPEECH, AND IT WAS DISGRACEFUL.
ENTHUSIASM DID IT OUTSIDE ON THE
STREETS IN FRONT OF A ROUGH
CROWD SO IT WAS DISGRACE TO THE
U.S. SUPREME COURT AND TO THE
SENATE.
>> MY ANALYSIS OF LAST NIGHT, IN
THE LEAD UP IT SEEMED THE MEDIA
IGNORED, THIS BERNIE SANDERS WAS
AGAIN DOUBLING DOWN ON
SUPPORTING ONE MURDEROUS
DICTATORSHIP REGIME AFTER
ANOTHER.
IT SEEMS LIKE THERE IS NOT A
WHOLE LOT OF POLICY DIFFERENCES
BETWEEN THE CANDIDATES, MAYBE
MIKE BLOOMBERG WAS AN EXCEPTION,
ON ISSUES BUT SUPPORTING
MURDERING DICTATOR SHIPS I WOULD
ARGUE IS A TIPPING POINT.
YOUR REACTION TO THAT AND DO YOU
THINK THAT IMPACTED LAST NIGHT
AND YOUR REACTION OVER ALL TO
LAST NIGHT.
>> I DON’T KNOW WHAT IMPACTED
I THINK ELIZABETH WARREN, DID
TERRIBLY LAST NIGHT BUT THIS SHE
WOULD HAVE BERNIE SANDERS WOULD
GOTTEN THOSE VOTES HE WOULD HAVE
WON TEXAS, MINNESOTA,
MASSACHUSETTS.
SO LEND WARREN REALLY, WHAT SHE
DID -- ELIZABETH WAR REMEMBER,
REALLY WHAT SHE DID, OTHERS LEFT
AND DROPPED OUT AND SUPPORTED
JOE BIDEN AND THAT REALLY
HELPED.
NOW, JOE DIDN’T WORK THAT OUT
BUT SOMEBODY IN THAT GROUP
WORKED IT OUT THAT WAS SMART,
BUT JOE WOULD NEVER BE ABLE TO
DO THAT.
BUT I WILL SAY, THIS BERNIE
SANDERS, IF HE WERE ABLE TO
CONVINCE ELIZABETH WARREN TO
ENDORSE HIM OR EVEN TO JUST DROP
OUT BECAUSE SHE IS DOING
TERRIBLY, HE WOULD HAVE WON A
LARGE NUMBER OF THE STATES THAT
HE LOST LAST NIGHT.
>> THERE ARE A LOT OF ISSUES
THAT I SEE, I KNOW THAT PEOPLE
ARE ACTING PERHAPS AS THOUGH IT
DOESN’T EXIST.
JOE BIDEN IS BEYOND A GAFFE
MACHINE, I WOULD ARGUE THE
TOUGHEST JOB IN THE WORLD YOUR
JOB, TO BE THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES, LEADING THE
WORLD.
YOU NEED STRENGTH, STAMINA,
FOCUS, THE ABILITY TO REACT IN
REAL TIME.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THESE
NUMEROUS GAFFES ARE JOE BIDEN?
>> WELL, LOOK, I DON’T WANT TO
BE TOO CRITICAL, I’VE NEVER SEEN
ANYTHING LIKE IT, TO BE HONEST,
AND I’M SURE THAT THE DEMOCRATS
ARE SAYING THE SAME THING.
BUT THEY WOULD RATHER HAVE HIM
THAN BERNIE, AND BERNIE DOESN’T
MAKE TOO MANY GAFFES BUT BERNIE
HAS HIS OWN DIFFICULTIES.
BUT THE WAY THEY PUSH, YOU KNOW,
THE MEDIA IS ALL ON THEIR SIDE,
WHEN I SAY ALL, ALL BUT A LITTLE
BIT, INCLUDING YOURSELVES AND
SOME OF THE FOLKS ON FOX.
SOME OF THE FOLKS AROUND.
YOU HAVE SOME GREAT PEOPLE, YOU
HAVE RUSH, WHO IS DOING I HEAR
REALLY WELL, MUCH BETTER, AND
MARK LEVIN.
WE HAVE A LOT OF SUPPORT.
YOU WOULD BE AMAZED, WE HAVE A
LOT OF SUPPORT.
THE GREAT LOU DOBBS, SO MANY
PEOPLE ARE SUPPORTERS OUT OF
JUST OUR FOX NEWS, WHICH, YOU
KNOW, I HAVE MY OWN LITTLE
DIFFICULTS WITH, IF YOU WANT TO
KNOW THE TRUTH.
THEY PUT PEOPLE ON I THINK ARE
INAPPROPRIATE AND SAY VERY, VERY
FALSE THINGS AND PEOPLE DON’T
CHALLENGE THEM.
I THINK THEY’RE TRYING TO BE
VERY POLITICALLY CORRECT OR FAIR
AND BALANCED, RIGHT IS TERM.
BUT I THINK THEY HURT
THEMSELVES, IF YOU WANT TO KNOW
THE TRUTH.
>> MR. PRESIDENT, I HAVE NOT
SEEN THIS REPORTED MUCH, THE
TURNOUT FOR YOU HAS BEEN RECORD
BREAKING, AND THAT GOES STARTING
BACK WITH IOWA, NEW HAMPSHIRE.
LAST NIGHT YOU RECEIVED MORE
VOTES IN VERMONT, MINNESOTA AND
MASSACHUSETTS THAN ANY INCUMBENT
IN THE LAST FOUR DECADES IN
COLORADO, REPUBLICAN TURNOUT
FOUR LAST NIGHT, UNCONTESTED
PRIMARY, GREATER THAN THE PAST
THREE REPUBLICAN PRIMARIES
COMBINED.
IN TEXAS YOU RECEIVED MORE VOTES
LAST NIGHT THAN BERNIE SANDERS,
JOE BIDEN AND LIZ WARREN
COMBINED AND WE’RE SEEING
SIMILAR RESULTS IN EVERY STATE.
HOW DO YOU INTERPRET THAT.
>> WELL, I APPRECIATE YOU SAYING
THAT.
I’VE HEARD THOSE NUMBERS, I’VE
NOT READ THEM IN ANY IMMEDIATE I
CAN’T RECOLLECT I DON’T READ
THOSE NUMBERS BECAUSE THEY DON’T
TELL US THOSE NUMBERS BUT THE
PEOPLE GET IT.
THE PEOPLE ARE GENIUS.
THE PEOPLE ARE BRILLIANT IN SO
MANY WAYS, THEY GET IT, BUT YOU
DON’T READ THOSE NUMBERS.
THOSE NUMBERS ARE NOT BROADCAST
FOR THE MOST PART.
I’VE NEVER SEEN THEM, I HEARD
THEM, HEARD THAT WE BROKE
RECORDS ALL OVER THE PLEASE AND
NEVER ONCE HAVE I SEEN IT AND
I’M PRETTY GOOD WITH THE MEDIA,
I SEE A LOT OF THE MEDIA, WHAT
IS GOING ON.
I HAVEN’T READ IT OR SEEN IT.
>> I LIKE TO PRIDE OURSELVES ON
THIS PROGRAM GIVING NEWS AND
INFORMATION THEY IGNORE.
LET ME ASK YOU, WE NOW KNOW THAT
THERE IS A CORRUPTION ISSUE AND
THERE IS AN INVESTIGATION
OFFICIALLY IN THE COUNTRY OF
UKRAINE AS IT RELATES TO JOE
BIDEN, WHO SAID YOU GOT SESSION
HOURS, YOU’RE NOT GETTING THE
BILLION UNLESS YOU FIRE THE
PROSECUTOR, INVESTIGATING
MY INEXPERIENCED SON HUNTER
BEING PAID MILLIONS.
AFTER ALL YOU WENT THROUGH AND
NOW SEE RON JOHNSON IN THE
SENATE AND UKRAINE INVESTIGATING
THIS ISSUE AND THEN THE OTHER
COUNTRIES SUCH AS CHINA, WRITES
ABOUT IT IN GREAT DETAIL THAT
HUNTER, AGAIN, NO EXPERIENCE,
MAKING TONS OF MONEY.
IT HAS TO BE A CAMPAIGN ISSUE.
HOW DO YOU PLAN TO TUESDAY OR TO
YOU PLAN TO USE IT?
>> WELL TO SHOW YOU HOW CRAZY IT
IT IS NOT A CAMPAIGN ISSUE FOR
THE DEMOCRATS, THEY DON’T WANT
TO BRING IT UP, THEY WERE TOLD
YOU CAN’T BRING THAT UP, SO EVEN
THAT WERE AGAINST, IF YOU LOOK
AT JOKE THEY ARE AGAINST JOE,
DON’T WANT TO BRING THAT UP.
THAT WAS OFF BOUNDS.
REPORTERS SAY IT WAS
UNSUBSTANTIATED, WE’RE SORRY TO
EVEN ASK YOU A REQUEST.
AND ANDERSON COOPER ASKS A
QUESTION THAT IS SO MILD, A
RIDICULOUS ANSWER WAS GIVEN
BECAUSE THERE IS NO ANSWER, OF
COURSE IT IS CORRUPT SO GIVE AS
REALLY BAD ANSWER AND GE TO THE
NEXT QUESTION, NOBODY SAYS
ANYTHING.
9 OTHER PEOPLE RUNNING TRYING TO
BEAT THEM DON’T BRING IT UP.
THAT WOULDN’T HAPPEN WITH THE
REPUBLICANS, I CAN TELL YOU.
NOT SAYING GOOD BAD OR
INDIFFERENT BUT THAT WOULDN’T
HAPPEN WITH THE REPUBLICANS.
THAT WILL BE A MAJOR ISSUE IN
THE CAMPAIGN, I WILL BRING THAT
UP ALL THE TIME BECAUSE I DON’T
SEE ANYWAY OUT.
FOR THEM, I DON’T SEE HOW THEY
CAN ANSWER THOSE QUESTIONS.
I HOPE THEY CAN, HE PREFER IT
THAT THEY CAN BUT I DON’T
BELIEVE THEY WILL BE ABLE TO
ANSWER THOSE QUESTIONS.
THAT WAS PURELY CORRUPT.
>> ANY THOUGHTS IN YOUR MIND WHY
YOU THINK BARACK OBAMA HAS NOT
ENDORSED HIS.
HAVE OF 8-YEARS.
>> I WOULD SAY HE DIDN’T THINK
COMAKE, IT DIDN’T THINK HE HAD A
SHOT AT IT.
HE IS DEALING WITH PEOPLE THAT
DIDN’T RATE THE HIGHEST ON THE
POLITICAL SCALE.
I KNOW EVERYBODY AND I WILL LOOK
AT EVEN THE PARTY, I KNOW PEOPLE
THAT ARE DEMOCRATS THAT ARE FAR
ABOVE WHAT YOU’RE WATCHING.
I WATCHED ONE NIGHT AND I LOOKED
AT THE CAST OF CHARACTERS, I
SAID THIS IS A 350 MILLION
PEOPLE AND THAT IS THE BEST WE
CAN, DO I DON’T THINK SO.
I WILL TELL YOU, I KNOW SOME
DEMOCRATS THAT WOULD BLOW ALL OF
THOSE DEMOCRATS AWAY.
BUT THEY DIDN’T RUN, MAYBE THEY
DIDN’T WANT TO RUN AGAINST ME.
I HEARD THAT, MAYBE IT IS TRUE,
MAYBE IT IS NOT, MAKES ME FEEL
GOOD BUT THEY’RE GOING TO WAIT
FOR ANOTHER FOUR-YEARS.
BUT YOU HAVE SOME DEMOCRATS THAT
ARE VERY IMPRESSIVE.
THIS IS NOT A GROUP THAT I THINK
WAS VERY IMPRESSIVE AT ALL.
>> MR. PRESIDENT, JOE BIDEN HAS
A RECORD.
HE SERVED AS.
HAVE FOR AGENT YEARS THAT RECORD
WOULD INCLUDE THE IRANIAN DEAL
THAT RECORD WOULD INCLUDE HOW
THEY REACTED AND RESPONDED WITH
THE H1N1 VIRUS, I WILL GET TO
THAT IN MORE DETAIL IN A MINUTE.
THAT RECORD WOULD INCLUDE 13
MORE MILLION AMERICANS AFTER
8-YEARS ON FOOD STAMPS, 8
MILLION MORE IN POVERTY, THE
LOWEST LABOR PARTICIPATION
RITZINESSES THE 70s, LOWER
HOME OWNERSHIP RATE EVERYONE
SINCE THE 40s AND THAT WOULD
INCLUDE THE ACCUMULATION OF MORE
DEBT THAN ALL 43 PRESIDENTS
BEFORE OBAMA/BIDEN COMBINED.
YOUR RECORD, HOW DO YOU COMPARE.
>> WHAT I THINK WE’VE DONE IS
UNPRECEDENTED.
THE LARGEST TAX CUTS IN HISTORY,
TRADE DEALS ALL OVER THE PLEASE.
THEY’RE GOING TO START KICKING
IN FAIRLY SOON.
UNFORTUNATELY, BY THE TIME TO
THE ELECTION THEY WILL JUST BE
PARTIALLY KICKED IN BUT THE TEAL
WITH CHINA, $250 BILLION A YEAR,
THE DEAL WITH JAPAN AND IT IS A
PARTIAL DEAL, I’LL GO BACK AND
GET BIGGER EVEN, BUT IT IS 40
BILLION A YEAR.
THE DEAL WITH SOUTH KOREA, THE
U.S.-MEXICO DEAL, THE U.S. -CAN
U.S. -CANADA DEAL, THE USMCA
COMBINED, ONE OF THE BIGGEST
DEALS.
THE DEAL WITH CHINA IS IN THAT
SEAM CATEGORY.
INCREDIBLE THING.
WE’VE REBUILT THE MILITARY,
TAKEN CARE OF OUR VETS.
WE’VE GOT CHOICE.
NOBODY THOUGHT WE WERE GOING TO
GET CHOICE.
THEY’VE BEEN TRYING TO GET CHOSE
FOR OVER 40-YEARS, VETERAN’S
CHOICE.
A VETERAN, IF THEY CAN’T SEE A
DOCTOR QUICKLY CHECK TO A
PRIVATE DOCTOR AND WE PAY THE
BILL.
IT IS A GREAT THING FOR OUR
COUNTRY AND VETERANS MUCH WE
HAVE ACCOUNTABILITY IF OUR
VETERANS ARE TREATED BADLY,
TREATED HORRIBLY, SAY WE HAD
SADISTS IN THE VA, ALL SORTS OF
PROBLEMS, THEY HAVE AS, YOU
COULDN’T DO A THING, COULDN’T
FIRE ANYBODY, I GOT
ACCOUNTABILITY PASSED WHICH IS
NOT EASY BECAUSE MUCH UNIONS AND
CIVIL SERVICE AND ALL OF THE
REASONS THAT EVERYBODY WOULD
UNDERSTAND VERY EASILY, WE GOT
THAT PASSED.
THEY’VE BEEN TRYING TO GET THAT
FOR MANY, MANY DECADES.
WHAT WE’VE DONE IS
UNPRECEDENTED.
NOBODY HAS DONE MORE IN THE
FIRST THREE-YEARS THAN WE HAVE.
ENVIRONMENTALLY, WE HAVE THE
CLEANEST AIR, CLEANEST WATER.
THARY IS AS CLEAN OR CLEANER
THAN IT HAS EVER BEEN, AND YET
WE’RE NOT SPENDING TRILLIONS OF
DOLLARS GIVING IT TO FOREIGN
COUNTRIES UNDER THE PARIS’ CORD,
YOU SEE WHAT IS HAPPENING WITH
FRANCE AND YOU SEE THE PROBLEMS
THEY HAVE BECAUSE OF IT AND
THEY’RE JUST TRYING TO TAKE OUR
WEALTH THAT WHOLE GROUP.
SO A LOT OF THINGS ARE
HAPPENING.
OUR ECONOMY IS DOING
FANTASTICALLY, WE GOT HIT WITH
THE CORONAVIRUS AND THAT WAS OUT
OF SURPRISE.
I STARTED HEARING ABOUT IT VERY
QUIETLY A COUPLE OF MONTHS AGO
FROM CHINA, AND I SAID, I HOPE
THAT DONALD HAPPEN OVER OVER
HERE.
IT GOT A LITTLE BIT MORE AND A
LITTLE BIT MORE AND BIGGER.
AGAINST THEORIES OF A LOT OF
GREAT PROFESSIONALS, FRACKLY
THAT WORK WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION AND OUTSIDE HE
CLOSED THE BORDERS TO CHINA AND
THAT IS WITH WE HAVE A VERY
SMALL NUMBER OF PEOPLE THAT WE
HAVE TO REALLY WORRY ABOUT AND
LOT OF THINGS HAVE HAPPENED THAT
HAVE BEEN VERY FORTUNATE.
BUT I CLOSED THE BORDERS AGAINST
THEORIES OF A LOT OF PEOPLE AND
IT TURNED OUT TO BE A VERY WISE
DECISION, OTHERWISE WE WOULD
HAVE HAD, YOU KNOW, A LOT OF
PEOPLE COMING IN DURING THAT
COURSE OF A NUMBER OF WEEKS SO
WE’RE DOING GREAT JOB.
A GREAT GROUP.
MIKE PENCE DOING A GREAT JOB,
PUT HIM IN CHARGE OF THE GROUP.
WE HAVE THE GREATEST DOCTORS IN
THE WORLD.
AND WE’RE HELPING OTHER COUNTRY,
WE WOULD HELP IRAN IF THEY
WANTED, THEY’RE LET’S VERY HIT V
BUT WE’RE HELPING A LOT OF OTHER
COUNTRIES.
>> MR. PRESIDENT, I HAVE THE
TIMELINE AND UNFORTUNATELY THESE
PAN DEM HE CANS POP UP, --
PANDEMICS POP UP, UNFORTUNATELY
PEOPLE DIE FROM THE FLU EVERY
YEAR.
THE MEDICAL PROFESSIONALS AND
SCIENCE CYSTS RISE TO THE
OCCASION ALL THE TIME.
I’LL GET TO H1N1 AND
BIDEN/OBAMA, HOW THEY REACTED.
THE W.H.O. IDENTIFIED ON
DECEMBER 30 THERE WAS A VIRUS
WITH PNEUMONIA LIKE SYMPTOMS.
IT WAS JANUARY 7 WHEN THEY
LABELED IT THE CORONAVIRUS.
I WANT TO GO TO YOUR DECISION OF
JANUARY 31 THAT WAS A TRAVEL BAN
THAT JOE BIDEN SAYS WAS XENO
PHOBIC ON YOUR PART AND CNN SAID
IT MIGHT STIGMATIZE PEOPLE FROM
COUNTRIES BUT YOU TOOK AN ADDED
STEP THAT WASN’T COMMON
COUNTRIES AND THAT WAS
QUARANTINES AMERICANS COMING
BACK FROM THE REGION.
THAT WAS ABOUT THREE-WEEKS AFTER
WE FIRST IDENTIFIED THE VIRUS.
YOU’RE SAYING PEOPLE RECOMMENDED
YOU NOT DO THIS, AND WHY AND WHY
DID YOU GO WITH THAT SO QUICKLY.
WHAT WAS YOUR RATIONALE AT THE
TIME?
>> WELL, HE WOULD SAY EVERYBODY
SAID IT IS TOO EARLY TOO SOON,
AND GOOD PEOPLE, YOU KNOW,
BRILLIANT PEOPLE IN MANY WAYS,
DOCTORS AND LAWYERS AND FRANKLY
A LOT OF PEOPLE THAT WORK ON
THIS STUFF ALMOST EXCLUSIVELY
AND THEY SAID DON’T DO IT.
AND MAY THEORY WAS THAT YOU
KNOW, WE TAKE A LOT OF PEOPLE IN
AND CHINA WAS BEING HIT HARD AT
THIS TIME, BY THAT TIME, WE
STARTED READING A LITTLE BIT
MORE ABOUT IT, IT WASN’T
SOMETHING THAT WAS GOING TO
AFFECT US.
YOU DON’T THINK OF IT IN TERM US
WHEN FIRST HEARD IT IN CHINA,
YOU DON’T THINK OUR COUNTRY IS
GOING TO BE AFFECTED, AND I
THOUGHT IT WAS A WISE THING TO
DO.
AGAIN, WE STOPPED TREMENDOUS
NUMBERS OF PEOPLE COMING IN FROM
CHINA AND THEN WE WORKED ON A
WHOLE WARTY SYSTEM WHICH WORKED
OUT VERY WELL.
ONE OF THE THINGS WE, DID THE
NUMBERS ARE SMALL WHEN YOU TALK
AROUND 100 PEOPLE BUT WE BROUGHT
IN APPROXIMATELY 40 PEOPLE FROM
A SHIP, THEY’RE AMERICANS BUT
THEY WERE ON A THEM, YOU KNOW
ALL ABOUT THAT, WE BROUGHT THEM
IN I KNEW WHEN I BRING THEM IN
MADE LIGHT NUMBERS GET HIGHER --
IMMEDIATELY THE NUMBERS GET
HIGHER.
WE’RE TALKING ABOUT VERY SMALL
NUMBERS IN OUR COUNTRY, VERY,
VERY SMALL, BECAUSE OF WHAT WE
DID WITH THE BORDERS.
I BROUGHT IN ACTUALLY,
APPROXIMATELY 40, A LITTLE BIT
MORE THAN THAT FROM OUTSIDE
BECAUSE THEY’RE AMERICANS, WE
HAD TO TAKE CARRY OF THEM.
THEY WERE LOAF IN OBEYIANCE, IN
THE MIDDLE OF NOWHERE, AND I
FELT WE HAD TO DO IT.
ONE WAY, I HEALTHED TO DO, IT
STATISTICALLY, FROM THE STAND
POINT OF COMING IN, IS IT GOING
TO LOOK BAD.
HE WASN’T WORRIED ABOUT THE
OTHER PEOPLE CAMPING IT SO MUCH
BECAUSE THE WARNTIES ARE GOOD
AND SET UP, A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE
GETTING BETTER AND WE WILL BE
RELEASING THEM.
WHEN PEOPLE ARE BETTER, WE
RELEASE THEM AND REDUCE OUR
NUMBERS, SO WE’VE BEEN DOING
REALLY WELL.
IT DOES HAVE A BIG IMPACT ON
OLDER PEOPLE AND PEOPLE THAT
AREN’T WELL, AND IT HAS VERY
LITTLE IMPACT ON YOUNG PEOPLE,
ESPECIALLY VERY YOUNG PEOPLE,
WHICH IS INTERESTING.
MUCH LESS SO THAN A LOT OF OTHER
INFECTIONS OR VIRUSES.
SO WE’VE LEARNED A LOT, WE’RE
LEARNING A LOT RIGHT NOW.
BUT OLDER PEOPLE LIKE THE
NURSING HOME IN WASHINGTON, THE
STATE OF WASHINGTON, HAS BEEN
VERY HEAVILY AFFECTED.
THE PEOPLE ARE MUCH OLDER AND
MANY OF THEM ARE NOT VERY WELL.
>> I KNOW, IT IS FUN YES YOU SAY
THAT BECAUSE THE H1N1 VIRUS,
THAT WAS A PANDEMIC IN 2009
AND ’10, INTERESTINGLY IN THE
OBAMA AND BIDEN YEARS, WE LOST
AROUND 17,000 AMERICANS.
THE CDC ESTIMATES ARE WE LOST
200 TO 500,000 LIVES WORLD WEED.
IN THAT CASE, CHILDREN WERE MORE
AT RISK WITH THE H1N1 PANDEMIC.
A DOCTOR WHO I’VE WATCHED FOR
YEARS, HE IS A GREAT SCIENTIST,
HE’S BEEN VERY CAUTIOUS AND YOU
KNOW HAS SAID THIS COULD BECOME
ANOTHER PANDEMIC, LIKELY
EXPERIENCED IN ’09 AND 2010, IT
MIGHT BE AS LONG AS A YEAR
BEFORE WE ULTIMATELY GET A
VACCINE.
THERE ARE 20 SPECIFIC VACCINES
PRESENTLY IN DEVELOPMENT.
YOU HAVE SAID THAT YOU ARE
EVALUATING ON A DAILY BASIS.
FOR THOSE AMERICANS THAT MIGHT
BE FEARFUL TONIGHT AM TALKING
ABOUT POTENTIAL DOWN THE ROAD WE
WILL CLOSE DOWN SCHOOLS AND
MAYBE MORE TELECOMMUTING WORKING
SITUATIONS, WHAT DO YOU SAY TO
THEM BASED ONS THAT DEVELOPS
WHAT ARE WE PREPARED AS COUNTRY
TOTO DO TO KEEP OUR CITIZENS SAF
>> IT IS A VERY, VERY SMALL
NUMBER COMPARED IN THIS COUNTRY.
THE H1N1 WAS COMMONLY REFERRED
TO AS SWINE FLU AND THAT WENT
FROM AROUND APRIL OF APTS 09 TO
APRIL OF ’10 WHERE THERE WERE 60
MILLION CASES OF SWINE FLU AND
YOU HAD OVER, ACTUALLY IS OVER
13,000 I YOU MIGHT HAVE SAID 17,
I HEARD IT WAS 13, BUT A LOT OF
DEATHS AND THEY DIDN’T DO
ANYTHING ABOUT IT.
INTERESTINGLY, WITH THE SWINE
FLU, CHILDREN WERE IN PARTICULAR
VULNERABLE, SORT OF THE OPPOSITE
IN THAT RESPECT BUT CHILDREN
WERE VERY VULNERABLE TO THE
SWINE FLU.
BUT THEY NEVER DID CLOSE THE
BORDERS, THEY NEVER HAD A TRAVEL
BAN AND WE IS AND THEY LOST AT
AT LEAST 13,000, COULD BE AS
HIGH AS 17,000 PEOPLE.
THEY REACTED MUCH DIFFERENTLY,
THEN, I WATCH BIDEN TRY AND
CRITICIZE US BUT I DON’T THINK
HE KNOWS WHAT HE IS CRITICIZING.
HE WATCHES SCHUMER, EVERY TIME
THEY PIT A MEC IN HIS FACE,
HEARS NO IDEA WHAT AND ANDEN AND
INCREDIBLE JOB.
BUT THAT’S HIS ANSWER, NO MATTER
WHAT YOU ASK HIM, HOW DO YOU
LIKE THE DEAL IN CHINA?
OH, EXCELLENT IT SAYING THEY
TOOK AWAY TARIFFS, NO THEY MAY
US A TAR HE HAVE OF 25% ON 250
BILLION.
HE DIDN’T WANT THE TARIFFS.
THEN, ALL OF THE SUDDEN WHEN HE
THINKS THEY WERE TAKEN AWAY, BUT
WE DIDN’T TAKE THEM AWAY, JUST
THE OPPOSITE.
IT WAS RATHER INCREDIBLE WE
DIDN’T TAKE THEM AWAY BUT THAT’S
THE WAY IT IS.
WE’RE GETTING ALONG WELL WITH
CHINA.
PRESIDENT XI WHO I SPEAK WITH,
PRESIDENT XI IS WORKING VERY,
VERY HARD IN CHINA.
THEY HAVE A BIG PROBLEM BUT
THEIR NUMBERS HAVE GOTTEN MUCH
BETTER WITH RESPECT TO THE
CORONAVIRUS.
VERY MUCH BETTER.
>> THERE ARE A COUPLE OF
ECONOMIC INDICATORS AND MARKETS
TEND TO BE SKIDDISH THOUGH IT
REALLY WASN’T DURING THE H1N1
SWINE FLU PERIOD WHICH IS
INTERESTING TO ME BUT THEY SEEM
TO BE ADJUSTING AN ACCEPTING
THAT ALL THE CAN BE DONE IS
BEING DONE.
WE HAVE SOME ECONOMIC NUMBERS
JUST OUT.
U.S. COMMITTEE SERVICE SECOND
GREW IN FEBRUARY AT THE FASTEST
PACE IN A YEAR.
CNBC REPORT ON ADP, THEIR JOB
REPORT, THAT THE ECONOMY ADDING
JOBS IN FEBRUARY, DESPITE THE
CORONAVIRUS SCARE AS PRIVATE
PAYROLLS EXPANDED.
THEY ARE SEEING EMPLOYMENT,
EXCLUDING GOVERNMENT JOBS, ROSE
BY 183,000 FOR THE MONTH.
EXPECT MAYBE A SHORT-TERM VERY
DOWN AT ALL IN THE COMMITTEE AS
A RESULT OF THE VIRUS AND MAYBE,
OF COURSE IT IS A GLOBAL
COMMITTEE, CHINA, THE IMPACT ON
CHINA’S COMMITTEE IN PARTICULAR.
>> I THINK WE’RE JUST DOING VERY
WELL, IT IS A VERY INTERESTING,
YOU KNOW, FOR YEARS YOU’VE KNOWN
ME AND I’M SAYING KEEP IT WITHIN
THE BORDERS A LITTLE BIT MORE,
MAKE OUR OWN MEDICINES HERE AND
WE’VE ALREADY STARTED THAT LONG
BEFORE I HEARD ABOUT THIS,
BEFORE WE KNEW ABOUT THE
CORONAVIRUS.
BUT I’VE STARTED IT, BUT I’VE
BEEN A BIG PERSON FOR LET’S KEEP
IT A LITTLE BIT INSIDE, I’M NOT
A GLOBALIST, I LIKE OUR COUNTRY
TO DO WELL AND I’M CERTAINLY
INTERESTED IN THE GLOBE, WE’RE
WORKING WITH THEM TO HELP THEM
IN A LOT OF DIFFERENT WAYS,
INCLUDING THE VIRUS THAT WE’RE
TALKING ABOUT RIGHT NOW.
I’M SAYING STAY HERE.
PEOPLE ARE ACTUALLY STAYING
HERE.
THAT’S OKAY, LET SOME TIME GO BY
AND THEY’RE STAYING HERE.
IF THEY WANT THEY CAN TRAVEL AND
THEY’RE GOING TO SAFE COUNTRIES.
HE MET WITH THE TOP AIRLINE
EXECUTIVES, TOP PEOPLE IN
VIRTUALLY EVERY MAJOR AIRLINE
TODAY IN THIS COUNTRY, AND
THEY’RE VERY AWARE OF IT AND
THEY’RE ENDING FLEETS TO CERTAIN
AREAS OF ITALY -- FLIGHTS TO
CERTAIN YEARS OF ITALY THAT HAVE
BEEN HIT HARD, NOT THE WHOLE
COUNTRY BUT CERTAIN AREAS.
AND CHINA, VERY BIG IN TERMS OF
CHINA.
SO A LOT OF THINGS ARE
HAPPENING, AND FRANKLY, IF
PEOPLE WANT TO SEND SPECIAL THEI
MONEY IN THE UNITED STATES
INSTEAD OF TRAVEL AGENCY BROAD,
THAT IS GREAT.
NUMBERS ARE COMING OUT WELL.
THE CONSUMER IN THE UNITED
STATES IS UNBELIEVABLY STRONG,
STRONGER THAN EVER BEFORE, I
BELIEVE.
THE EUROPEAN UNION IS NOT DOING
WELL.
PARTS OF ASIA AND CHINA NOT
DOING WELL, AND WE’RE DOING
GREAT.
SO I THINK WE’RE GOING TO BE IN
GREAT SHAPE.
AND THIS WILL GO AND THIS WILL
PASS AND WORKING ON VACCINES
RIGHT NOW, WE’RE WORKING ON
THERAPEUTIC MEASURES AND WORKING
AT A LOT OF THINGS.
I WAS WITH SOME OF THE GREATEST
DOCTORS IN THE WORLD IN THE LAST
TWO-DAYS AND THEY’RE SAYING WHAT
THEY CAN DO TODAY.
IT IS INCREDIBLE WHAT THEY’RE
DOING AND ABLE TO DO, AND THEY
CAN DO IT MUCH FASTER SO WE’RE
GETTING VERY GOOD IDEAS AND I
THINK YOU CAN HAVE THINGS
HAPPENING PRETTY QUICKLY.
>> YOU EXTENDED YOUR TRAVEL BAN,
MET WITH THE PHARMACEUTICAL
COMPANIES IN THE COUNTRY.
HE UNDERSTAND YOU’RE GOING DOWN
IT ATLANTA TO MEET THE CDC
LEADERSHIP.
YOU HAVE.
HAVE MIKEPENSE AT THE HELM FOR
RUNNING THIS TASK FORCE, IT
COULD GET WORSE AND AT TEAMS WE
MEET HAVE TO TAKE MORE SEVERE
SAFETY MEASURES.
WE HAVE THE GLOBAL DEATH RATE AS
3.4 PRESIDENT AND A REPORT THE
OLYMPICS COULD BE DELAYED.
YOUR REACTION TO THAT.
>> I THINK THE 3.4% IS A FALSE
NUMBER.
NOW, THIS IS JUST MY HUNCH, BUT
PEACED AND LOT OF CONVERSATIONS
WITH A LOT OF PEOPLE THAT DO
THIS, BECAUSE A LOT OF PEOPLE
WILL HAVE THIS AND IT IS VERY
MILD.
THEY WILL GET BETTER VERY
RAPIDLY, THEY DON’T EVEN SEE A
INTEREST OR CALL DOCTOR, YOU
NEVER HEAR ABOUT THOSE PEOPLE SO
YOU CAN PUT THEM DOWN IN THE
CATEGORY, THE OVER ALL
POPULATION IN TERMS OF THIS
CORONA FLU, OR VIRUS.
SO YOU JUST CAN’T DO THAT.
SO IF, YOU KNOW, WE HAVE
THOUSANDS OR HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE THAT GET
BETTER, JUST BY, YOU KNOW,
SITTING AROUND AND EVEN GOING TO
WORK, SOME OF THEM GO TO WORK,
BUT THEY GET BETTER AND THEN,
WHEN YOU DO HAVE A DEATH LIKE
YOU HAD IN THE STATE OF
WASHINGTON, LIKE YOU HAD ONE IN
CALIFORNIA, I BELIEVE YOU HAD
ONE IN NEW YORK, YOU KNOW, ALL
OF A SUDDEN IT SEEMS LIKE THREE
OR 4%, WHICH IS A VERY HIGH
NUMBER, OPPOSED TO A FRACTION OF
1%.
, BUT AGAIN, THEY DON’T KNOW
ABOUT THE EASY CASES BECAUSE THE
EASY CASES DON’T GO TO THE
HOSPITAL, THEY DON’T REPORT TO
DOCTORS OR THE HOSPITAL IN MANY
CASES SO I THINK THAT THAT
NUMBER IS VERY HIGH.
I THINK THE NUMBER, PERSONALLY,
I WOULD SAY THE NUMBER IS WAY
UNDER 1%.
WITH THE REGULAR FLU, WE AVERAGE
FROM 27,000 TO 77,000 DEATHS A
YEAR.
WHO WOULD THINK THAT.
I NEVER KNEW THAT UNTIL SESSION
OR EIGHT-WEEKS AGO, I ASKED THAT
QUESTION, HOW MANY PEOPLE DIE OF
THE FLU.
YOU KEEP HEARING ABOUT FLU SHOT,
FLU SHOT, TAKE YOUR FLU SHOT BUT
HOW MANY PEOPLE DIE OF THE FLU.
SO WE LOSE BETWEEN 27,000 AND,
YOU KNOW, SOMEWHERE IN THE70s,
I THINK WE WENT AS HIGH AS
100,000 PEOPLE DIED IN 1990, IF
YOU CAN BELIEVE THAT BUT A LOT
MUCH PEOPLE REGARDLESS, I THINK
IT AVERAGES ABOUT 36,000 PEOPLE
A YEAR.
I SAID, WOW, THAT IS A
PERCENTAGE THAT IS UNDER 1%
SUBSTANTIALLY.
IT IS INTERESTING TO SEE WHAT
THAT DIFFERENT DIFFERENCE IS, A
PEOPLE DON’T REPORT BECAUSE THEY
GET THE CORONAVIRUS AND GET
BETTER RELATIVELY QUICKLY, NOT
THAT SEVERE.
>> WHAT DO YOU SAY ABOUT THE
POLITICS IF YOU KALE TERRORIST
NAMED SOLOMANI, NUMBER ONE STATE
SPONSORED TERRORIST IN IRAN, THE
GUY LEADING THOSE TERRORIST
EFFORTS, A MIRACLE WITH OUR
INTELLIGENCE, 99% OF GOOD
INTELLIGENCE OFFICIALS THAT
TRACKED HIM DOWN A BAGHDAD
AIRPORT, KNOWING HE WAS IN A
COMMERCIAL AIRPORT, THEY COULD
HAVE SHOT DOWN THE PLANE BUT WE
CARE ABOUT HUMAN LIFE AND THEY
INDICATED NEL WASINDICATE WAITED
THE GROUND.
YOU DON’T GET A LOT OF SUPPORT,
WE CAN AGREE THE UNTIL IT IS
NONBE DISKRIMM DISKRIMM NEATING,
ATTACKED FOR IT.
XENOAPHOBE, STIGMATIZING
COUNTRIES.
I ASSUME YOUR BEST INTENSION TO
PROTECT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
>> THE DEMOCRATS WEAPONIZE
EVERYTHING WE DO IF THEY DID IT
THEY WOULD BE HAILING IT, BUT DO
THEY WEAPONIZE IT.
THEY KNOW WHAT A GREAT JOB WE’RE
DOING, THEY KNOW WE HAVE THE
BEST IN THE WORLD AND WE’VE
REALLY SHOWN IT.
EVEN WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE SMALL
NUMBERS IN THIS COUNTRY, THEY’RE
VERY, VERY SMALL.
WE HAVE A VERY LARGE COUNTRY TO
PUT IT MILDLY AND A GREAT
COUNTRY, BY THE WAY, AND IT IS
GETTING GREATER ALL THE TIME.
THEY WEAPONIZED THE VIRUS
AGAINST US AND THEY WILL JUST
SAY, EVEN THOUGH THEY HAVE NO
FACTS OR JUST WE DON’T LIKE THE
JOB THEY’RE DOING, IT IS JUST
OFF THE CUFF, LIKE A NATURAL
REFLEX, AND IT IS NOT GOOD
ESPECIALLY IT IS NOT GOOD WITH
SOMETHING LIKE THEM THEY CAN SAY
IT ABOUT CERTAIN THINGS BUT THIS
ONE EVERYBODY HAS TO PULL
TOGETHER.
NOT ALL DEMOCRATS HAVE DONE
THAT.
LATELY I NOTICE IT HAS GOTTEN A
LOT LESS, I WOULD SAY 50% LESS,
BUT THE SAME, THE BAD ONES.
THE SHIMMERS AND OTHERS, --
SCHUMERS AND OTHERS THEY WILL
ALWAYS SAY NO MATTER HOW GOOD DO
YOU, IF YOU FOUND A CURE AND
EVERYTHING DISAPPEARED IN
24-HOURS, THEY WOULD SAY YOU DID
A TERRIBLE JOB.
THAT IS UNFORTUNATE FOR THE
COUNTRY, AND WE LIVE WITH IT AND
HERE I AM IN THE WHITE HOUSE,
I’M PRESIDENT AND THEY’RE NOT,
SORT OF AN AMAZING.
>> IN 244-DAYS THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE ARE THE ULTIMATE JUSTIFY
RE.
GO BACK TO THE ELECTION FOR A
SECOND.
IT WAS VERY LEGAL EARLY ON WHEN
BLOOMBERG GOT IN THE RACE.
HE SAID YOU’RE WASTING YOUR
MONEY.
WHY DID HIS CAMPAIGN NOT CATCH
ON.
>> ONCE HE DEBATED, HE WAS IN
TROUBLE, THAT’S NOT HIS THING.
HE HAS VERY BAD POLITICAL
INSTINCT.
HE IS SURROUNDED BY PEOPLE THAT
I KNOW, IN SOME CASES, I KNOW
PRETTY WELL, THEY’RE LOSERS.
HE IS REALLY SURROUNDED BY
LOSERS BUT THEY BECOME WINNER
BECAUSE THEY RIPPED OFF FOR A
LOT OF MONEY, REALLY TOOK HIM TO
THE CAREEN CLEANERS.
SOME OF THESE GUYS ARE THIRD
RATE, AND THE LONGER HE GOES,
THE MORE MONEY THEY MAKE.
THEY KNEW IT WAS NOT FOR HIM.
I THOUGHT THE STRATEGY WAS
INCREDIBLE WHEN THE DNC WOULDN’T
LET HIM INTO THE DEBATES.
HE SHOULD HAVE KEPT THIS THAT
WAY.
I DON’T THINK HE COULD HAVE WON
BUT HE WOULD HAVE DONE MUCH
BETTER.
HE DID REALLY BADLY.
TODAY HE SAID I’M GOING TO
SUPPORT JOE BIDEN, AND THAT’S
OKAY.
THAT’S FINE.
I DON’T KNOW HOW YOU CAN DO IT,
HOW DOES CAMPAIGN FINANCE LAWS,
HOW DO THEY LET YOU DO THAT.
HE COULDN’T GET OUT FAST ENOUGH.
HE WITH A ON THE DEBATE, A VERY
MEAN PERSON, YOU CAN ASK BERNIE
SANDERS BECAUSE WHAT SHE HAS
DONE TO HIM IS TERRIBLE, BUT
WHEN ELIZABETH WARREN WENT AFTER
HIM, GET ME OFF THIS STAGE FAST.
HE GOT BEAT UP VERY BADLY BY
ELIZABETH WARREN, IT WAS SO BAD
THAT WAS THE END OF HIM.
RIGHT THERE HE WAS UNDER ABLE TO
RECOVER FROM THE DEBATE
PERFORMANCE, ESPECIALLY THE
FIRST ONE.
>> ARE YOU CONVINCED NOW IT IS
BIDEN’S TO LOSE?
I THINK SO, BUT JOHN HOW I DON’T
HE GETS THERE.
HE WAS ALWAYS GAFFE PRONE, FALSE
TROUBLE IN THAT WAY BUT NEVER
LIKE THIS.
IF THEY THINK HE CAN DO BETTER
WITH BERNIE, THEY HAVE LESS
CONTROL OVER BERNIE.
HE WAS SURPRISED WHEN BERNIE
GOOD BEATEN UP LAST TEAM HE WENT
OUT AND ENDORSED HELLERY AND
WENT AROUND AND -- LIKE GOOD
PUPPY LIKE YOU’RE SUPPOSED TO
DO, I WAS LITTLE SURPRISED AT.
THAT EVEN THIS TIME, SAYING
ABOUT HOW WONDERFUL JOE BIDEN IS
A WONDERFUL GUY, WONDERFUL MAN
AND I’M A LITTLE BIT SURPRISED
BY IT, IT IS ALMOST LIKE -- I
DON’T KNOW IF HE IS ADMITTED
DEFEAT, HE MIGHT BE, I WATCHED
HIM YESTERDAY, A LITTLE WHILE
AGO SAYING VERY GOOD THINGS
ABOUT SLEEPY JOE BIDEN AND I WAS
A LITTLE BIT SURPRISED.
>> LET ME ASK YOU, IN 2016, YOU
HAD ABOUT 8% OF THE
AFRICAN-AMERICAN VOTE.
WE’VE CARRIED A LOT OF YOUR
RALLIES, AS YOU POINT OUT IN
EVERY APPEARANCE THAT YOU HAVE
RECORD LOW UNEMPLOYMENT NOW FOR
AFRICAN-AMERICANS, HISPANIC
AMERICANS, ASIAN AMERICANS, WE
WILL IN THE WORK PLEASE, YOUTH
UNEMPLOYMENT, AFRICAN-AMERICAN
YOUTH UNMOBILITY.
HE CAN CITE YOU POLLS WITH
AFRICAN-AMERICAN SUPPORT FOR
DONALD TRUMP ANYWHERE FROM 16 TO
34.5%.
ONE CASE 33%.
ANOTHER CASE 32%.
DO YOU THINK THAT THESE -- WHY
DUKE THESEDO YOU THINK THESE APP
RATINGS DEMLY HAVE SHIFTED, ONE,
AND TWO, WILL THAT TRANSLATE TO
VOTES IN 244-DAYS?
>> IT SHOULD TRANSLATE BUT I
THINK ONE OF THE REASONS IS
CRIMINAL JUST TEST REFORM, I IS
IT, NOBODY ELSE COULD HAVE DONE
IT.
WE GOT SOME GREAT REPUBLICAN
SENATORS THAT MAYBE WEREN’T SO
INCLINED AND I EXPLAINED IT TO
THEM AND THEY WERE REALLY GREAT.
I SAWAL LESS JOHNSON TODAY SHE
RECOLLECTS WAS IN JAIL 22-YEARS
AND HAD ANOTHER 20 TO GO.
THERE WAS A CRIME THAT, YOU
KNOW, SHE ADMITTED SHE DID A
MISTAKE, BUT SHE WAS IN THERE
FOR IT, WAS LIKE A LIFE SENTENCE
FOR SOMETHING THAT SOMEBODY ELSE
WOULD HAVE BEEN GIVEN SIX-MONTHS
TO A YEAR FOR OR A VERY SMALL
NUMBER.
SHE IS A GREAT WOMAN AND I SAID
YOU HAVE OTHER PEOPLE JUST LIKE
YOU, ALICE, JUST LIKE YOU.
SHE SAID, YES THERE OTHER
PEOPLE.
I ACTUALLY LET THREE OUT THEM
ALL CAME TO THE OFFICE TODAY,
GREAT TO SEE THEM.
BUT I THINK THAT CRIMINAL JUST
TEST REFORM, WE GOT THAT, I GOT
THAT, THE DEMOCRATS DID NOT GET
IT I GOT IT.
THEY WILL PROBABLY AT SOME POINT
TRY AND TAKE CREDIT BUT THEY
COULDN’T DO IT.
AGAIN, THIS WAS A BIDEN/OBAMA
LAW THAT WAS, THIS WAS
OBVIOUSLY, IT WAS REALLY A
HILLARY, THIS WAS A BILL CLINTON
AND HILLARY AND IT WAS, I GUESS
BIDEN WAS A SENATOR THEN AND
PUSHING IT HARD.
OBAMA WAS SOMEBODY SAID HE WAS
TALKING ABOUT IT BUT HE HAD TO
BE PRETTY YOUNG, IF THAT WAS THE
CASE.
BUT THIS WAS HORRIBLE THING.
SO CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM,
SCOTT, A GREAT SENATOR AND GREAT
SENATOR FROM SOUTH CAROLINA AND
HE CAME TO MY OFFICE, TALKED
ABOUT OPPORTUNITY ZONES AND
MASTIFF AMOUNTS OF MONEY IS
BEING POURED INTO AREAS THEY
HAVEN’T SEEN IN DECADES AND JOBS
AND PEOPLE BE DOING WELL,
HISPANIC AMERICANS ARE DOING
INCREDIBLY WELL.
WITH THE OF LOWEST BLACK
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE, IF YOU LOOK
NOW, THE BLACK COMMUNITY HAS THE
LOWEST UNMOMENT RATE IN THE
HISTORY OF OUR COUNTRY.
THE HISPANIC AMERICAN LOWEST
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE IN THE HISTORY
OF OUR COUNTRY.
ASIAN, LOWEST IN THE HISTORY OF
OUR COUNTRY.
WE WILL THE LOWEST IN 71-YEARS.
SO MANY THINGS ARE HAPPENING, IT
IS TRUE, WE’RE HAVING RALLIES
NOW WITH BLACK YOUNG LEADERS WHO
ARE UNBELIEVABLE PEOPLE.
THEY WILL COME TO THE WHITE
HOUSE AND HAVE RALLIES NEWS
DIFFERENT STILLS AND TRUMP IT IS
THE FIRST TEAM THEY’VE REALLY
BEEN HELPED.
THE DEMOCRATS SAY CATER TO THEM
A MONTH BEFORE AN’ ALEXANDER AND
THEN THEY LEAVE AND DON’T -- AN
ELECTION AND THEN THEY LEAVE AND
DON’T A THING FOR THEM.
I THINK CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM
AND OPPORTUNITY ZONES, IT IS
INCREDIBLE.
WHAT KIM SCOTT DID WITH
OPPORTUNITY ZONES IS INCREDIBLE
AND HOW WELL IT WORKED.
BUT THE END RESULT IS THE LOWEST
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE AND I THINK
PEOPLE SEE THAT STRONGLY.
>> THERE IS A LOT OF SUPPORT FOR
HISTORICALLY BLACK COLLEGES IN
THE COUNTRY YOU CAN AS WELL.
LET ME ASK YOU THIS:
>> THE HISTORICALLY BLACK
COLLEGES, HE GET TO KNOW THE
DEANS AND TOP PEOPLE WHEN THEY
COME, I AM AT OR ABOUT HERE MORE
THAN THREE-YEARS, THEY COME
TRYING TO GET MONEY.
EVERY TWO OR THREE-YEARS I SAY
WHY DO YOU HAVE TO COME BACK,
THEY SAY WE ALWAYS HAVE TO COME
BACK, WE FEEL LIKE BEGGARS
COMING TO THE WHITE HOUSE BIGS
FOR MONEY.
I SAID WE SHOULDN’T HAVE TO DO
THAT AND I GOT THEM LONG-TERM
FINANCING FOR THE HISTORICALLY
BLACK REJS AND COLLEGES AND UNIV
SUCH AN INCREDIBLE GROUP OF
PEOPLE AND INCREDIBLE AND
IMPORTANT FUNCTION, AND IT IS A
VERY LARGE, YOU KNOW, YOU’RE
TALKING ABOUT MILLIONS OF PEOPLE
ARE EDUCATED AND TAKEN CARE OF
AND IT IS REALLY SOMETHING GOOD,
BUT THEY DON’T HAVE TO DO THAT.
THEY DON’T HAVE TO COME BACK.
I SAID I’LL MISS YOU PEOPLE NOT
COMING UP TO SEE ME, I’LL MISS
YOU GUYS, YOU GALS, NOT COMING
UP TO SEE ME EVERY YEAR, BUT I
DON’T THINK THEY COULD BE ANY
MORE THANKFUL, THEY DON’T HAVE
TO BOTHER NOW, THEY DON’T HAVE
TO DO THAT.
>> WHEN YOU INSTITUTED YOUR
TRAVEL BAN ON JANUARY 31, WE
IDENTIFIED CORONAVIRUS ON
JANUARY 7 AND THE QUARANTINE, IT
WAS IN THE MIDDLE OF YOUR
IMPEACHMENT.
JAMES COMEY, ALL OF YOUR RALLIES
YOU SAY THIS SHOULD NEVER HAPPEN
TO ANY FUTURE PRESIDENT, YOU
FIRED JAMES COMEY.
WE KNOW ALL ABOUT THE DIRTY
RUSSIAN DOSSIER THAT WAS NEVER
VERIFIABLE, THE TOP OF A FISA
WARM SAYS VERIFIED WE NOW KNOW
IT HAS BEEN DEBUNKED, HILLARY
PAID FOR IT AND BILL THE BASIS
FOR THE VIOLATIONS TO TAKE AWAY
CARTER PAGE’S RIGHTS AND MORE
IMPORTANTLY IT WAS USED TO SPY
ON YOU, AND THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
CONFIRMED THIS, TO SPY ON YOU AS
A CANDIDATE, A IN HIS WORDS,
DEEP INTO YOUR PRESIDENCY.
I KNOW THAT WE’VE HAD THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL WEIGH IN NOW
WE HAVE THE DURHAM BARR
INVESTIGATION GOING FORWARD.
WITHOUT CROSSING INTO TERRITORY
THAT I ASSUME IS DIFFERENT, HOW
DOES THIS -- HOW DO WE PREVENT
SOMETHING LIKE THIS EVER
HAPPENING.
I AM A BIG BELIEVER, WE NEED
FISA, WE NEED TO TRUST MEANS
WITH THESE POWERFUL TOOLS
BECAUSE WE’VE GOT A LOT OF
ENEMIES IN THIS WORLD BUT IT
RAISES QUESTIONS IF IT IS TURNED
ON THE AMERICAN PEOPLE OR A
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE OR A
PRESIDENT.
>> WELL, THEY WEAPONIZED FISA
AND USED IT HORRIBLE YES AND
COMB GENTLEMEN A VERY BAD GUIDE
AND YOU HAVE OTHER VERY BAD
PEOPLE AT THE TOP.
THE F.B.I., THE PEOPLE IN THE
F.B.I. ARE INCREDIBLE.
I’LL BET IF THEY DID A STUDY, IF
YOU TOOK A VOTE, I WOULD HAVE A
VAST, VAST, VAST MAJORITY, THEY
ARE INCREDIBLE PEOPLE.
BUT THE TOP PEOPLE, THE PEOPLE
THAT HEADED IT BETWEEN COMEY AND
McCABE AND STRZOK AND HIS
LOVER, LISA PAGE, THE WHOLE
GROUP, A BAD GROUP.
THAT IS MY OPINION AND A VERY
STRONG OPINION AND WE WILL SEE
HOW BAD IT WAS.
IT WAS A TERRIBLE THING AND A
LOT OF VERY INNOCENT PEOPLE WERE
HURT.
>> I THINK WE HAVE A DISHONEST
MEDIA.
IN 2007 AND 2008 WE WILL SAID
JOURNALISM MEASURE IS DEAD.
I’M PROUD OF THE ENSEMBLE CAST
WE BUILD, WE TORE APART THE
ESPIONAGE ACT AND CLASSIFIED TOP
SECRET INFORMATION ON HILLARY’S
SUBPOENA AND DELETED E-MAILS AND
THE DOSSIER, WE’VE BEEN
VINDICATED WITH THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL REPORT.
AND I GUESS, I NEVER THOUGHT
THAT THIS COULD HAPPEN IN
MEASURE, BUT THE MEDIA GOT IT
WRONG.
RUSSIA, RUSSIA, UKRAINE, UKRAINE
AND THAT’S BEEN LOT TO GO
THROUGH.
>> IT HAS, BUT THEY KNEW IT WAS
WRONG AND THEY KNEW THEY WERE
WRONG AND THE WHOLE THING, THIS’
WHY I CALL IT THE FAKE NEWS FOR
THAT AND MANY OTHER REASONS BUT
IT IS FAKE NEWS.
SO.
OF IT IS FAKE AND KNOWINGLY
FAKE.
AND THEY KNEW THAT WAS WRONG,
THEY KNEW THE FIRST DAY IT
SHOULD HAVE NEVER HAPPENED, BUT
I WENT THROUGH IT, I DID IT AND
YOU THINK OF IT AFTER MILLIONS
THEY SPEND, MILLIONS AND
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS AND AT THE
END HAD UNLIMITED RESOURCES, NO
COLLUSION, SOMEBODY SAID YOU’RE
THE CLEANEST PERSON IN THE
COUNTRY.
BUT IT WAS A DISGRACE.
A LOT OF PEOPLE WERE HURT AND
HURT BADLY.
LET’S SEE WHAT HAPPENS GOING
FORWARD.
>> ALL RIGHT, MR. PRESIDENT,
YOU’VE BEEN VERY GENEROUS WITH
YOUR TIMISM KNOW YOU’RE DOING A
TOWN HALL ON FOX HERE TOMORROW
WITH PRETTY AND MARTHA,
QUESTIONS FROM THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE, WE’LL LOOK FORWARD TO
WATCHING THAT.
YOU’RE ALWAYS GENEROUS WITH YOUR
TIME, WE LIKE TO GET THE STATE
OF THE CAMPAIGN, CREDIT, A LOT